[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette édition
annuelle d'infos ou intox cette année
pour la semaine de la presse et des
médias dans l'école nous sommes au lycée
paul valéry à paris avec ahmed al
bataoui professeur de lettres et
d'éducation aux médias
[Musique]
nous avons suivi pendant plusieurs
semaines vos élèves de seconde ils sont
en classe média qu'est ce qu'ils
apprennent dans cette classe la classe
médias donc les initie à l'éducation aux
médias qui une partie donc de leur
programme scolaire au lycée et cette
année deux objectifs d'abord comment
voir la fabrique de l'information et a
surtout décrypter les fausses
d'informations sur les réseaux sociaux
puisque c'est là où ils obtiennent la
plupart de leurs informations c'est
qu'on va regarder tout de suite le
résultat de ce travail avec vos élèves
qui se sont transformés en véritables
vérificateur de l'information
pour les lycéens les réseaux sociaux
sont incontournables dans la vie
quotidienne notamment pour s'informer
mais ils le savent bien des rumeurs et
des contenus trompeur peuvent circuler
sur ces plateformes
avec la classe médias du lycée paul
valéry à paris nous allons travailler
sur les bons réflexes pour démêler le
vrai du faux
jo allez vous je m'entraîne
bonjour à tous donc moi je suis
journaliste pour france 24 et on a une
émission qui s'appelle info ou intox
dans laquelle on décrypte des rumeurs
qui ont pu circuler sur les réseaux
sociaux des images trompeuses avec vous
on va essayer de voir comment on arrive
à repérer ces contenus là est ce qu'il y
en a qui s'informent déjà exclusivement
par les réseaux sociaux ici
et tu va regarder quoi par exemple les
actualités
sur lequel gilles goupil président
serons nous leur montrons des images
vérifié par notre rédaction et nous leur
demandons s'ils ont vu des informations
douteuses récemment sur leurs réseaux
sociaux
à landreau s'est fait vacciner si on met
notre téléphone mais ça a collé à moi ça
fait beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux on
t'attend ne pensais pas mais moi je n'y
croyais pas j'y crois pas parce qu'un
des trolls aussi les gens qui font
défaut sa désintox par exemple il ya des
faucons des fois qu'ils sont passés pour
des réponses mais ça je reconnais qu'ils
sont certifiés ils ont le sort de lego à
côté de l'homme donc ça nous permet de
savoir s'ils sont pas fiables petrotec
qui sont pas certifiés et parfois il ya
des comptes qui sont pas certifiées
est-ce que du coup tu vas faire
confiance en fait ça dépend ça dépend
des haches ou si c'est le truc qui
paraît possible on va faire confiance
plus facilement je regarde si par
exemple
journaux fiable parle moi je regarde les
commentaires je vois ce qui les gens y
voit ici c'est détourné aux pages
[Musique]
les élèves ont déjà de bons réflexes de
vérification de l'information pour aller
plus loin nous leur donnons rendez vous
la semaine suivante cette fois direction
la salle informatique pour apprendre à
vérifier des images
quand on reçoit une vidéo comment on
fait pour voir si elle a déjà circulé
ailleurs sur internet est ce que il y en
a qui ont déjà un peu fait ça
quand vous voyez des informations comme
ça circule et ça vous pose question
quand même de savoir d'où viennent ces
images parce que les images il est bref
et ce que je dis pas je vais partir
surprotech ce tout ça ça c'est des
questions que tu te poses oui est-ce que
tu arrives à le vérifier c'est en fait
je sais pas trop qu'on est en fait du
bruit pose plus quand je vous dis pas
tous comme ça mais je pense pas vu les
élèves vont tenter de vérifier cette
vidéo d'une bousculade dans un
supermarché
sur twitter elle est partagée par cet
internaute qui nous dit belgique jours
de promo chez lidl à molenbeek molenbeek
c'est un quartier de bruxelles où
beaucoup d'habitants sont issus de
l'immigration dans les commentaires on
peut lire il se comporte comme au bled
mais que montre vraiment cette vidéo
donc ceux qui ont déjà utilisé un peu
google images comment on va faire pour
essayer de retrouver ou cette vidéo
circule sur internet
ok bon on teste ça on fait tous une
capture d'écran de la vidéo
pour faire une recherche d'image
inversée il suffit d'importer dans un
moteur de recherche comme google images
où il y en des qs une photo ou la
capture d'écran d'une vidéo
allez sur le moteur de recherche yandex
et grecs à mdx votre
montre
vous avez trouvé l'article est ce que ça
vous a semblé compliquer
tous les élèves ont retrouvé l'origine
de la vidéo elle n'a pas été prise en
belgique mais en algérie en mars 2021
lors d'une importante pénurie d'huile
bravo d'avoir réussi à vérifier ça vous
paraît clair alors et enyele à vos
ordinateurs
nous allons maintenant nous intéresser à
une intox repéré par les élèves
sur tik tok et d'autres réseaux sociaux
plusieurs vidéos montrent des auto test
de dépistage au co vite 19 donnant un
résultat positif avec de l'eau certains
internautes se demandent si le colis de
19 pourrait être présent dans l'eau
d'autres remettre en question la
fiabilité de ces tests
allaient en fait un test
voilà deux bars donc testé positif avec
de l'eau du robinet trop bien et tesco
dit est-ce qu'il y en a qu'on les
impressions face à cette vidéo très
inquiète j'ai pas encore et je connais
pas la raison dans la culture et la vie
bien ça a pu faire qu'est-ce qu'il fait
peur moi je sais que je peux y croire
surtout c'est un jeu lent surprise en
jeu mais encore tu crois
qu'ils pourraient nous répond pour
savoir si des autotests c'est fiable et
s'il ya deux du pauvre dans l'eau
une partie de la classe se lance dans
des recherches pour comprendre où et
quand a circulé cette rumeur
[Musique]
d'autres élèves préparent des questions
pour une interview avec un virologue
qu'on aimerait savoir si les autres
tests sont fiables on a une concordance
par rapport aux télé spéciale dans huit
fois sur dix c'est de toute façon il
faudra le confirmer par un test pcr
[Musique]
positif
la question du coup sûr ça c est ce que
c'est possible que l'eau soit positive
comme il ya des laboratoires qui analyse
les eaux usées pour voir s'il ya des
traces de kovy dedans mais dans l'eau du
robinet n'y en a pas
façon même dont les ont usé ligne à des
virus en section est ce que vous pensez
que ça a un impact ces vidéos là sur
l'opinion publique aujourd'hui le
problème des des réseaux sociaux c'est
que tout le monde a un avis sur tout et
très intéressant d'analyser ce cas dans
les vidéos attention
bon bah merci en tout cas pour cet
entretien
journée
[Musique]
nous proposons aux élèves de présenter
le résultat de leurs recherches en
fabricants eux-mêmes un épisode de notre
émission info ou intox alors ce qu'on va
faire les présentateurs vous êtes prêts
on peut enlever nos masques la commande
est dehors manon et savoure sont à la
présentation etc timothée qui va les
filmer approchez-vous fonctionne un
cadre complet recule un peu comment as
tu eu ni pas tu vois ça alimatou et ruth
ont le texte des présentateurs sous les
yeux
satan certaines vidéos ont été vues
milliers de fois
ça tourne bien villes mortes et plus de
spécial d'affronter hawks ok on remballe
et puis on va aller voir le reste de la
classe
la semaine suivante nous montrons aux
élèves le résultat de leurs émissions
finalisé par les équipes de france 24
bienvenue dans cet épisode spécial d'un
four il a été réalisé pour la semaine de
la presse dans l'école en france avec
les élèves de la seconde 5 du lycée paul
valéry à paris auto test positif au kovy
19 avec de l'eau du robinet il faut
qu'on m'explique
on nous montre avant tout et ce
qu'affiche un état positif avec de l'eau
du robinet depuis début janvier ce genre
de vidéos circulent sur tic tac twitter
ou facebook certaines vidéos osées t il
digne de foi
des vidéos similaires ont été réalisées
dans d'autres pays l'eau du robinet est
testée positive au co vide un autre
exemple de la farce absolue de cette
crise fabriquée de toutes pièces neuves
antigénique positif avec l'eau du
robinet
alors pour vérifier la rumeur nous avons
posé des questions un virologue
si vous mettez de long du caucase qu'on
voulait sur le test il est pas fait pour
ça ça va modifier les paramètres à du
test c'est injuste un test
colorimétrique avec une oxydation donc
si vous voulez à ce moment là il est
plus valable l'eau en tant que tel à eux
contenir des fragments d'un arn du
coville c'est possible surtout les eaux
usées mais dans l'eau du robinet n'y en
a pas donc conclusion des expériences
avec deux ne prouve rien si on utilise
malin d'autotest on peut obtenir
n'importe quel résultat et non l'eau ne
peut pas être positives aux côtés de 19
c'était au fond on tox avec les élèves
quelles sont vos réactions c'est
représentatif de ce qu'on a ce qu'on a
fait
bon je vous paie est ce que le travail
de recherche et d'analysé d'image a été
pour toi quelque chose d'utile ça vous a
donné des outils fidji pour un trip
contre la france en la fausse
information maintenant je vais me poser
plus de questions et ses devoirs c'est
vrai ou faux et je vais réfléchir sur
l'information il essayait de la traiter
un grand merci aux élèves de la seconde
5 du lycée paul valéry à paris on espère
que vous aussi vous avez appris des
réflexes de vérification car face à une
information sur les réseaux sociaux il
est important de se poser des questions
de croiser les sources et parfois de
faire une recherche d'image inversée
pour retrouver le contexte derrière une
photo ou une vidéo à bientôt dans info
ou intox
[Musique]
on le peut pas je t'appelle pour te dire
qu j'étais envoyer un peu d'argent je
sais tu veux dire que je n'aurais pas
dit mais je veux vraiment que tu fous là
le jour nouveau mariage pour nom fait
avec moi
[Musique]
oh
en envoyant de l'argent vous en voyez
bien plus que de l'argent western union
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]